hi i'm simul liu and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
let me do it one more time let me do one
more time i feel like i the first one
was magic and the fact that you weren't
roll i'm just so sad all right all right
hi i'm simulu and this is my wired auto
complete interview
that was perfect okay fine all right
first we have how cmu view so
how
tall is simulator it's a wonderful
question top of the morning straight out
of bed with a nice platform on the shoe
i could hit about six feet but but
probably usually walking around i'm a
lot closer to 511 which is really
it's not great it's not great the
difference between 5 11 and 6 foot it's
so disheartening feeling like you're
right on the cusp really unfortunate but
uh clearly i've worked my way through
this insecurity um as you can
obviously tell
let's move on how did seymou
start acting basically i was working as
an accountant out of college i hated my
job was was also terrible at my job and
then about eight months in before i
turned 23 i got fired and kind of on a
whim i signed up to be an extra the
first time i was on set i i just
absolutely fell in love with all of it
and basically made a promise to myself
that i was just going to keep trying to
find opportunities to to be on set it's
almost been 10 years now and i'm still
still just looking for opportunities so
yeah if you know anybody uh that knows
anybody please let them know how simulu
got chang-chi
i auditioned for it i was it was a
three-step audition process at first i
was asked to send in a self-tape um i
had no idea what i was auditioning for
but i kind of knew it was for something
important
something perhaps marvel related but but
i didn't know for sure kind of didn't
hear back for a while and then all of a
sudden was invited to la for a callback
audition i met uh dustin daniel
the director of the movie we had an
incredible audition um and um and i came
out of that feeling like oh my god like
just that electric feeling of like you
just nailed a job interview or something
i just kind of came out feeling like
that lo and behold a couple days later i
got invited to new york to do a screen
test the screen test is basically like
your final round audition it's like all
the decision makers are present you show
up you get your hair and makeup done you
get you know your wardrobe everything
the whole nine yards as if you were
working on set i remember aquafin was
there it was the first uh time that i
met her and i was just absolutely so
star trek because she's so cool and uh
and then we did the scenes and then two
days after that i got a call from kevin
feige that i got the part it's uh it's
it's still crazy to me but uh here we
are next
how did simulu get famous
do a really good woe for tick tock
you know that's about it
all right now for some geography
questions where was cmu liu
raised i was born in harbin china i was
raised by my grandparents my dad showed
up at our door and was like hi i'm your
dad first of all crazy mind blown and
then he was like i'm here to take you to
your new life in canada so i was like
okay so when i was about four and a half
five i i immigrated to canada with my
with my parents first city was uh
kingston ontario where my where my
parents were doing grad school and then
we lived in etobicoke and then my
parents were able to buy a house in
mississauga ontario where they actually
still live where does simulu live in
toronto um that's private no i have a i
have a nice little apartment
downtown and it's really fun and i never
get to spend any time there anymore and
i miss it very much
where is simulu in pacific rim
okay so deep cut thank you for for
bringing that up um so pacific rim
awesome incredible movie it also happens
to be the first movie that i was
an extra on so there's a first set that
i had ever set foot on and i skipped
work to be on that side which is
probably one of the reasons why i got
fired but i dragged my best friend jason
with me i remember we got we basically
were told to strip down and then we were
spray painted blue from head to toe
for whatever reason i think it was
because blue is like the color of the
alien blood we get told later that it's
actually not like water soluble and the
only way to get it off your body was to
was to use shaving cream anyway long
story short kind of came out of that
experience we're like okay great like i
hope we make it to the screen uh months
later we are watching pacific rim in the
theater i don't see me at all i'm not
kidding there is a
extreme close-up on jason where he is
holding like an animatronic alien bug
thing and it's literally just three
seconds on his face and there's nobody
else in the shot when i say that i was
jealous
it doesn't even begin to describe i was
like i dragged you you're here because
of me
where
where did simulu um
okay
i'm trying to i'm trying to really pull
back here and try i'm trying to where
did c move you or did c move you hmm
toronto i would say 2012
getting laid off was it was a pivotal
moment in my life
because it was the moment that i
realized that
i can't spend my life working
on somebody else's version of success it
was the first time that i made the
decision to
do something for me and only me and it
was the best decision i ever made
is cmu liu so the burning questions of
the of the internet is simulu in season
five of kim's convenience uh i am we
were actually able to shoot a piece of
that season while i was still in
australia it was the only time that
kim's convenience was
shot in a country outside of canada and
it was super cool is cmu view an
accountant um no no i'm a i'm a failed
accountant
is simulu in doctor strange seeing as
doctor strange came out many years ago
you can clearly see that i am not in
doctor strange now if the question were
is simulinu and doctor strange too i
would have the exact same answer because
i'm also not in doctor strange too
i'm kidding i'm really i'm not it's
similar
um
yes i am the worst i never tip i never
tell you when your shoelaces are untied
no none of those things are true i don't
know i don't know i think if you were to
ask my friends they would they would say
no
but um maybe i was mean to somebody
at some point in time
was simulu in his stock photo not only
was simulu in a stock photo simuliu
quite possibly
is the most successful stock photo model
of all time because i just keep popping
up in random places on corporate
e-learning websites textbook covers
pamphlets brochures various reading
paraphernalia these stock photos will
not die i am stuck with them for the
rest of my life and there's nothing i
could do about it so
there you go
will simulu be in more marvel movies now
that is a million dollar question i
don't know how the sausage is made all
right i just know that we did a great
job with shanxi i know that everyone is
super super happy with it and i know
that there's a lot more story to tell
with the characters so if i were a
betting man i would say that uh
i would say that i would ready simulator
celebrity game face yes i did a game
show called celebrity game face i'm
still mad about it because i won every
other round and in the last final round
for some reason it was worth like 10
times as many points we were asked to
scavenger hunt for things i was in a
house i'm not trying to point any
fingers wanda sykes some some
contestants were in hotel rooms where
everything was like like two feet away
not me i had to go up the stairs i had
to come anyway anyway it didn't win even
though if you watched the episode i i
should have
simulu beauty and the beast not um not
your version of beauty and beast not
disney's beauty and the beast beauty and
the beast on the cw was it was a show
that i was on i played emt number one
my director was debra chao
she is currently working on obi-wan
kenobi on disney plus hey deborah got
any room in there i don't know my
character only had five lines and that
was because in the industry if you're an
actor and you have five lines or under
you're considered an under five and so
you get paid a slightly lower amount so
i just started like improving i just
started throwing lines out there i
waited around when the episode came out
all of my improv made it into the final
cut and so i was like yes and i called
my union rep and i was like i have more
than five lines in this and and because
of that i got i got like 700 extra
dollars which at the time was like a lot
of money so it's pretty sneaky okay
simulu
marvel tweet yes
in uh 2014 i tweeted hey at marvel great
job with captain america and thor how
about an asian superhero and it was very
tongue-in-cheek and nobody ever read it
but then five years later i
uh became chunchy so um pretty crazy
starting to feel a little like
nostradamus and i'm wondering what other
crazy prophecies i have you'll have to
get back to me um i have a very specific
process and i cannot be rushed next
question simulu
jumping over hedge yes this is a
reference to the met gala we kind of
came out of the met there are these um
steps that lead to the to the street
level and i saw jimmy fallon kind of
like maneuvering himself over the ledge
to say hi to the fans that had kind of
lined up and so i thought oh my god
that's incredible so i did the same
thing i kind of parkoured myself over
the ledge and i and i went over and i
and i spent some time with the fans
final and perhaps most importantly
what simuliu ready
what is simulu
known for what is simula you know for
i'm known for being way too
uh
stupid on social media for never
finishing my drinks i always leave a
little bit at the bottom and maybe for
this show kim's convenience which ran
for five seasons and also for this
little movie uh called shanxi and the
legend of the ten rings which is uh on
disney plus now
next and oh god we're doing
not great in terms of the
maybe it's the way that i'm peeling them
but you know what i can read it what
movies has cmu liu been in well
there's the marvel movie
and that's it i have um
a lot of dream
roles in my head i mean i always wanted
to play like uh tom cruise-esque you
know spy guy i've always wanted to be in
space i've always wanted to be a jedi
basically all the things that i dressed
up as when i was a kid those are things
that i want to do again as an adult and
get paid money for what martial arts
does cemu liu
no to be honest i didn't know that many
going into the movie i had
done some like boxing some stage
fighting some muay thai basically
anything that would get me work as a
stunt man in toronto but once i got the
part i went into this massive training
intensive and a lot of it revolved
around chinese kung fu and chinese
martial arts i got to do
tai chi quite a bit of it wing chun
hungar i got to be very mediocre at a
lot of it but i worked really really
hard and i really i did my best so
hopefully you liked it what does simulu
eat
i know a lot of you
will assume that i'm probably on some
super strict diet and that was certainly
true for parts of our production but i
think in life i really love food so i'm
a big like korean barbecue guy i love
going to k-town i love hot pot i love
like big group meals that you know you
have a bunch of friends sitting around a
table i just feel like that's kind of
the best
last one here what languages does c
movies speak in espanol it would be qual
idiomas
not spanish i was born in in harbin
china so i grew up speaking mandarin and
uh when i immigrated to canada when i
was about five that my primary language
switched over pretty fast to english so
unfortunately my my mandarin is is
slowly deteriorating and i'm looking
forward to
going back to china and uh and getting a
little refresher i had a lot of fun
answering all of google's burning
questions and um i'm really looking
forward to
doing it again sometime oh and um watch
watch sanchi in the legend of the 10
rings honestly it's the best and
thanks so much